President Trump is coming to Texas in a
few hours he promised yesterday that
storm victims will get all the help that
they need right now the single most
important thing is the safety and
security of those still in harm's way
including the first responders
protecting the lives of our people is my
highest priority every asset at my
command is at the disposal of local
officials
major Garrett is at the White House with
the president's plans for today's visit
major good morning good morning
president Trump faces the first great
natural disaster of his presidency
possibly one of the worst in American
history and the multiple tasks of rescue
operations organizing shelter and
providing basic commodities will
severely test Federal Emergency Response
officials for days if not weeks to come
those tasks overwhelmed president george
w bush and louisiana officials after
Katrina with disastrous political and
humanitarian consequences now the
president the first lady will leave the
White House shortly landing in Corpus
Christi Texas about 11:25 a.m. Central
time to survey damage there and meet
with federal emergency management
officials as well as the National Guard
then the president the first lady had on
to Austin Texas arriving about 1:30
Central time to tour the jort Emergency
Operations Center and get briefed by
Texas governor Greg Abbott this trip
will necessarily avoid flood ravaged
Houston no point in having a president
there to siphon away valuable resources
a one former FEMA administrator told us
President Bush did not go to New Orleans
immediately after Katrina because he
didn't think the city was ready to take
a presidential visit and didn't want to
be a distraction at that time president
said yesterday he may return to Texas
and possibly Louisiana on Saturday he
also said he expects Congress to swiftly
approve the billions that will be
required for recovery of Houston and
other parts affected by Hurricane Harvey
Nora
all right major thank you